foreign
good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the College of
Arts and Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National Institutes
of General Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series is focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence deep
learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's chosen theme is data
science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where we'll enjoy
presentations on Fridays from leading thinkers
about the issues the promises the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covid-19 these
include delayed Health checkups treatments Mental
Health Health drug abuse increased obesity in the
long lingering health effects associated
with long covet participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations
as vital material in our culminating in-person
Community Development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle Washington
in June of 2023. today I'm delighted to welcome
our speaker Dr Paul Perrin from the school
of data science at the University of Virginia
all parent is a professor of data science
and psychology here at UVA he received his
Bachelor of Arts degree in English and a BS
in Psychology from the University of Florida
before going there to receive his master's of
Science in Psychology and his PhD in counseling
psychology with a concentration in industrial and
organizational psychology and systems intervention
he trained clinically at the University of
Florida Counseling Center and the spinal cord
injury and polytrauma units at the Tampa Veterans
Affairs Medical Center he conducted an internship
at Baltimore Veterans Affairs Medical Center
and the user University of Maryland school of
medicine followed by a postdoctoral fellowship
at Virginia Commonwealth University where he
later joined the faculty Dr Perrin is a licensed
clinical psychologist in Virginia and continues
to supervise Clinical Psychology doctoral students
in community settings and in his research he uses
a combination of data science modern analytic
techniques and community-based participatory
research approaches as key to understanding and
identifying the sources of Health disparities
this work covers three facets cultural familial
and international approaches to disability
Rehabilitation social determinants of Health
and Social Justice approaches to understanding
and dismantling oppression in continuing our
2022-2023 biomedical data science seminar series
theme Paul's lecture today is entitled statistical
modeling and covid-19 early pandemic Telehealth
implementation and mid-pandemic post-covered
neurobehavioral symptoms in Paul's presentation
today he's going to Showcase a diverse set of
data science approaches for modeling important
features of the covid-19 pandemic including
analyzes of variance linear regression path
analysis and network analysis he'll present
data and results documenting and predicting
the rollout of Telehealth services at the
beginning of the pandemic by psychologists
and physicians in the United States and he'll also
discuss data and results concerning the magnitude
and patterns of neurobehavioral symptoms and long
covered from across diverse Global regions as all
always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you're joining
us on YouTube thank you so much for joining also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions for Paul
via the chat feature in their Zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and I'll ask
them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that Paul thank you
so much for joining us we've been really looking
forward to hearing what you have to tell us about
all right well thank you so much for the
invitation to present and to everyone for
attending this talk today and thank you Dr
Van Horn in particular for going through
my agenda so I don't need to do it again
but yeah essentially this is going to be
a two-act performance if you will so I'll
be talking about the rollout of Psychology
Services in the U.S at the beginning of the
pandemic and then I will be presenting some
information on a neurobehavioral symptom
magnitudes and patterns in Long covet
all right so for uh that First Act um so
this is uh I'm going to be presenting the
results of two different papers uh from a
single data collection so these papers were
published in 2021 in the American psychologist
and also in the journal of clinical psychology
um in order to talk about telepsychology we
should probably start by discussing what it is so
you know telepsychology is broadly defined as the
provision of Psychological Services via technology
and unfortunately before the covid-19 pandemic
very few psychologists were using telepsychology
in their clinical practice only about 21 of
psychologists across the U.S endorsed that use of
telepsychology there are a number of deterrents
and reasons why psychologists didn't want to
use it or were unable to use it um you know they
they broadly had concerns surrounding practice so
things like having received insufficient training
in their doctoral or a postdoctoral programs and
not knowing how to handle client safety or crisis
issues that might come up maybe insufficient
Demand by the patient populations that they were
working with and also they had concerns about
the efficacy you know they were not sure whether
telepsychology approaches to clinical work were
as effective as in-person modalities they also
reported a number of environmental and policy
concerns so issues of privacy you know using the
right type of video conferencing technology to
to ensure inpatient privacy big concerns about
legality for example if you know patients across
state lines then you know what happens with
a provider's license when they're licensed to
practice in a particular State a lot of ethical
issues that can come up around confidentiality
reimbursement problems for services by Managed
Care organizations and also just prohibitive
organizational policies and cultures a lot of
providers were working in environments where
there were just explicit rules against using
telepsychology for their clinical practice
but you know as uh everybody's aware in
March of 2020 uh March of 2020 the who
declared uh the covid-19 uh pandemic and as
a result there was just profound shutdowns
in schools businesses institutions and a lot of
uh Human Services transitioned to online models
and one of the biggest changes that we
saw had to do with Health Care delivery
where a lot of elective procedures were being
postponed in routine patient visits were also
being postponed or conducted virtually
but at the beginning of the pandemic no
studies had documented the shifts in Psychology
clinical practice to telepsychology despite a
lot of widespread and first-hand accounts and
providers saying that they had made this shift
so as a result we decided to launch a study right
at the beginning of the pandemic and our purposes
of this study were one to examine the amount
of psychologists telepsychology use before The
covet pandemic during the pandemic and then their
anticipated use after the pandemic ends second was
to examine the demographic training policy and
clinical practice predictors of these changes
then the third was to use key elements from
respected Behavior change models to develop and
test a theoretical model of psychologist adoption
of telepsychology use during the covid-19 pandemic
so for uh participants to to be a part of the
study they had to be licensed to practice as a
psychologist in the U.S at least 18 years
of age or older and currently practicing
or in other words seeing patients as a
psychologist within the United States
so data were collected from May 11 2020
to May 25th 2020 and as a result uh the
the paper that came out of this the first
paper was the first paper uh documenting
the rollout of telepsychology services across
the U.S so it was published July 20th of 2020.
um so for recruitment uh we we sent initial
and follow-up email invitations to about 27
000 psychologists so we CL we pulled
a bunch of contact information from
publicly available email lists websites Clinic
contact information sites and then we got about
3 600 participants who started the survey so
about a thousand of these individuals didn't
provide informed consent didn't complete the
survey or they provided kind of nonsensical
or impossible responses or they had lack
of a meaningful response to a validity
check question so our final sample was 2619
licensed currently practicing psychologists
sorry it's stuck
yeah there we go all right here's what these folks
look like so their average age was uh 57 in their
average years in clinical practice was 24 years so
this is actually a pretty well seasoned uh sample
of psychologists uh about two-thirds were women
about 91 identified as white or European American
and these demographics uh generally mirror the
overall demographics of the membership of the
American Psychological Association a lot of
these individuals were individual practice so
54 percent reported being um you know in an
individual practice in the community 15 in a
group practice and then largely in other types
of medical centers whether that's uh VA medical
centers academic medical centers outpatient
treatment facilities psychiatric hospitals
uh 46 were in a suburban area 44 we're in an
urban area and about nine percent in a rural area
and about 44 of these psychologists were the
only ones in their private practice uh 33 had
about two to five psychologists in their practice
and then a number particularly those who were in
Health Systems had a much larger number of
psychologists in their practice so when we
defined uh telepsychology to these participants
we called it the use of real-time audio for
example telephone and or video conferencing
technology to provide Psychological Services
and we asked psychologist what percentage
of your patient treatment is provided
using telepsychology and so they responded
from zero percent to one hundred percent
and we asked them to respond with regard to three
different time points so one was before the covid
pandemic began in the U.S on January 20th 2020
which was when the first documented case occurred
in the United States during the covet pandemic
in the US so in other words currently and then
your anticipated perspective or behaviors
after the kova 19 pandemic ends in the U.S
and here are results so before the coveted
pandemic about eight percent of clinical
work was performed via telepsychology during
the pandemic about 85 percent was performed
via telepsychology and then psychologists
estimated that about 35 percent of telecent
of clinical work would be performed by a
telepsychology after the pandemic ended
um so you know we were doing work in the context
of telepsychology in this space for a number of
years before the covid pandemic and a big goal of
ours was really to try to increase the adoption of
telepsychology and the research has suggested that
it is equally as effective as in-person treatment
for literally every type of evidence-based
practice that has been tested and we could not
get much movement in the uptake of telepsychology
no matter how many presentations we gave research
articles we published and so because of this
incredible shift we called this the telepsychology
Revolution and it truly was a revolution there's
a 12-fold increase in uptake of telepsychology
and as you might imagine this was a statistically
significant change partial Ada squared of 0.863
we're not supposed to call things very large
size effect but it was a very large size effect
when we broke this down about
45 of psychologists reported
not using telepsychology at all before the
pandemic and then 85 percent reported it for
using it using it 10 or less of their
clinical work so very very little use
um before the pandemic during the pandemic 96
of psychologists reported using it in their
practice 67 reported that they were going
completely virtual during the pandemic and
almost 78 reported using telepsychology
for 90 or more of their clinical practice
after the pandemic 89 percent of psychologists
anticipated continuing to use it in their work
so then we broke up using just
a series of analyzes of variants
um who what type of psychologists were likely to
use telepsychology during these different time
periods so before the coveted pandemic we had
the highest use of telepsychology with the by
those who are working in VA medical centers so the
US Department of Veterans Affairs has been a huge
proponent of telepsychology and Telehealth and
they've really been a forerunner in the context
of the provision of services via Telehealth
that was followed by individuals in private
practice so we're seeing people who probably had
a lot fewer barriers to practicing telepsychology
because they could just make their own
decisions as an independent practitioner
conversely of those who worked in outpatient
treatment facilities had the lowest use of
telepsychology before the code pandemic followed
unfortunately by those in academic medical centers
during the pandemic the highest use
was from those in individual practice
lowest use was by a psychologists
in hospital and Medical Practice
and then the change in telepsychology use is a
little bit of a wonky variable to look at so I
won't present it because it has to do with how
much they were using it before versus the change
but in terms of projected use afterwards
after doing bond for only Corrections we
found no differences in the projected use after
the coveted pandemic would end so again just
robustly across the board we're seeing people who
are very very likely to be using telepsychology
we then conducted a simple linear
regression to see what demographic
characteristics might predict increased
use of telepsychology during the pandemic
so we found a positive a small size effect of
psychologists who had been trained sufficiently
in the use of telepsychology they were
more likely to use it during the pandemic
those who worked in an organizational setting had
supportive telepsychology policies were also more
likely to use it psychologists who identified
as a woman were more likely to use it and there
was a lot of research literature published at the
time about women having to play kind of dual roles
of you know working and then also looking after
kids and taking sort of a differential burden of
child care responsibilities so we interpreted
this uh in line with that larger literature
and then there was a very very small size
and barely statistically significant effect
of rural locations so psychologists who are
practicing in rural areas were less likely
to use telepsychology during the pandemic which
was a bit surprising to us and might be in line
with kind of social distancing Norms in rural
regions that were occurring in the us at the time
psychologists who treated anti-social
personality disorder were less likely
to use fellow psychology and
we thought that a lot of these
folks might be in kind of forensic
settings like correctional facilities
those who perform testing and evaluation
were less likely to use telepsychology as
many psychological assessments actually have not
been adapted for for telepsych administration
psychologists who treated relationship issues
were more likely to use telepsychology and
this is also in line with a lot of research
literature suggesting that couples conflicts
and domestic violence were increasing during the
pandemic so psychologists who tended to treat
these were probably very likely to be able
to use those services to um to provide care
psychologists working focusing in physical
medicine and rehabilitation so this is taught
populations like traumatic brain injury spinal
cord injury and also a lot of psychologists who
are working in medical centers those folks
were less likely to use telepsychology
and then so this was just looking kind of a
basic demographic so here we've seen the use of
really basic analyzes of variants to look at mean
differences in in use of telesite whether that's
based on before the pandemic during the pandemic
or projected after we also saw this looking at
different practice locations then we're moving to
regression modeling to see how either a different
focus of treatment or also different demographic
characteristics predict a higher percent use
of telepsychology but we were interested in a
little bit more complex modeling Beyond what's
traditionally used in Psychology research um
and there's been two predominant models of
behavior change uh in the research literature
that we wanted to draw from to see if some of
the variables within those models especially
if we used path modeling might describe some
of the uptake of telepsychology so the theory
of reason to action is a very traditional model
of behavior change it was developed in 1975 and
it's been applied to a lot of different topics
like health behavior change for example you know
changing one's diet or engaging in exercises or
medication adherence and it's kind of a basic
model but the idea is that there are subjective
Norms around particular behaviors like if you uh
you know are a part of a social network that's
very likely to exercise or eat healthy subjective
Norms affect behavioral intentions to engage in a
behavior and then a person's attitudes about that
behavior also are likely to affect their intention
to engage in that behavior so whether they think
that the behavior will be effective in its outcome
um and then that behavioral intention is
theorized to lead to actual Behavior change
so then this model we had attitudes toward
telepsychology subjective Norms about the
use of telepsychology so whether
psychologists believe that other
psychologists were likely to use telepsychology
all of those things channeled directly into
intention to use telepsychology which then uh
transitioned into current use of telepsychology
so the uh the parameter estimates
here are all standardized beta weights
and when a lot of times when researchers conduct
a path analysis they'll start with What's called
the saturated model so they will draw all
potential paths within a system of theorized
connections and so that's what we did so we had
an additional path going from attitude toward
telepsychology to current use of telepsychology
and you can think of each of these as kind of
standardized beta weights within a regression so
each of them is the unique effect controlling for
the other effects within the model so there
was no statistical effect of attitude toward
telepsychology directly on current use of
telepsychology once we control for intention
to use telepsychology so that is considered a
full mediation with subjective Norms going to
intention to use telepsychology and then current
use we still have that additional beta weight of
0.12 and the systems of indirect effects the two
possible indirect effects here or mediational
effects of intention to use telepsychology were
statistically significant so from subjective
Norms because there is still a statistical effect
there we would consider this a partial mediation
now the cool thing about path modeling is that
you can sort of draw out a theoretical model and
then you can apply fit indices to that theoretical
model to see how well the real world data actually
map on to your model and so over here we have a
number of fit indices NFI IFI tli and CFI where
0.90 is or higher is considered adequate 0.95
or higher is considered a good fitting model
rmsca the root mean square error approximation
traditionally 0.08 or lower is considered adequate
0.05 or lower is considered good and we have a
AIC and Bic Criterion as well so here all of the
with the theory of reasoned action all of the fit
indices were excellent they're actually perfect
and so overall we found pretty good
support for the theory of Reason
action in describing psychologists use of
telepsychology in their clinical practice
right we then also had the technology acceptance
model which is a specific model applied to use
of a new technology and so it was uh developed
in 1989 and of course was not really applied to
telepsychology until uh more more recent times
uh and we were the first group of researchers
to apply it so here a person believes
that a new technology is useful or not
over on the left they also have perceptions
about the ease of use of that new technology
those two variables are theorized then to drive
attitudes toward using the new technology which
then drive behavioral intention to use
it and then drive actual system use
so here we did the same thing with perceived
usefulness received ease of use going to
attitude toward telepsychology to intention
to use telepsychology and then current use of
telepsychology and then within the model
perceived usefulness generally exerted a
stronger statistical effect on attitude toward
telepsychology than perceived ease of use did and
it uh also exerted an effect directly to intention
to use telepsychology so all of the possible
indirect effects or statistical effects including
multiple mediational effects were statistically
significant within this model so we're seeing
sort of good internal support for it based on that
system of inter of indirect effects um but then
we're also seeing a partial mediation of attitude
toward telepsychology on the relationships
between perceived usefulness and intention
and then perceived ease of use and intention and
then so this model is describing for is explaining
47 percent of the variance and intention to use
telepsychology and then 33 percent of the variance
in current use and we also had excellent fit
indices here not quite perfect like we did with
the theory of Reason action but nonetheless
extremely good fit indices so we're finding
support both for the theory of Reason action
and also for the the technology acceptance model
for describing why psychologists might or might
not be using telepsychology during the pandemic
so the implications of these findings is
you know we had excellent fit of both these
models and so the models suggest Pretty
right targets for increasing psychologist
provision of telepsychology both during
the coveted pandemic but also Beyond
so there are a number of changes that the
centers for Medicare Medicare Medicaid
um implemented in terms of reimbursement of
telepsychology at the same rate as in-person
visits and so what we're arguing is that you know
some of those policies are extremely likely to
continue to increase psychologists perceptions of
the usefulness and improve their attitudes toward
the use of telepsychology so we highly recommend
that you know governmental agencies enforce you
know comparable reimbursement structures for
telepsychology versus in-person business and
again all of the literature suggests that they're
equally effective and so why not reimburse them
at the same rates particularly to support the
continued rollout of telepsychology services
we also recommend that legislation particularly
that involving HIPAA with regard to practice
across state lines and license revision for
services across state lines um you know continuing
to support those changes what ameliorate concerns
related to legality and confidentiality that
psychologists have that have been found over
and over in the previous literature is one of
the major barriers and again if we remove that
barrier then you know we're theorizing that a
lot of the variables in the theory of Reason
action and Technology acceptance model then are
going to increase in the positive direction which
then set off that theoretical Cascade of effects
all right end of act one we can transition now to
act two uh focusing on neurobehavioral symptoms
and long covet so uh the the findings
from this uh uh for the for this part of
um the talk are going to be from a single
study also although a separate study from
uh the first one that I mentioned and this is
part of two papers that were recently published
in 2022 in the journal Inter National Journal
of Environmental Research and Public Health
all right so you might have heard of the term
long covet it's also uh been called persistent
post covet syndrome and it's a set of symptoms
that appear after infection by the SARS Cove
2 virus and that persists for four weeks or more
After The Infection some researchers have uh have
um given it sort of a eight week uh or longer
time window although uh four weeks or later is
is fairly common in the research literature
as well now long covet is more common in
individuals with severe Copa 19 presentations
but it also can appear in people who had mild
infections and so some of the symptoms are ones
that you might be familiar with these are things
like fatigue General bodily pain headaches
breathing difficulties anxiety and depression
but there also are a lot of long coveted
neurological symptoms including headaches
dizziness loss of smell loss of taste also a more
serious neurological conditions like prolonged
loss of consciousness stroke encephalopathy
meningitis seizures and demyelinating diseases
there are three overarching theories about why
long coveted neurological symptoms exist and
so the idea is that the virus attacks the
brain and you know these theories do have
some scientific support to them so the
first is with direct virus infection to
the astrocytes so astrocytes are these sort
of star-like structures within the central
nervous system that are thought to regulate
cerebral blood flow among other functions
second is overreaction of the immune
system which has been termed cytokine storm
and then also a blockage of blood flow in the
brain causing causing hypoxia or a lack of oxygen
so when we conducted this study the literature
is really lacking in Long coveted studies and
particularly those with large sample sizes
those from diverse Global regions and also
those using validated instruments so a lot of
researchers were kind of creating their own yes
no checklist of symptoms that may or may not
actually have been validated psychometrically
so the purposes of this study were to
compare the presence of somatic cognitive
and emotional neurobehavioral symptoms
and a large International sample of covid
uh International sample of individuals as
recalled before their covid-19 diagnosis
during their covid-19 infection and currently
or in other words at the time of their survey
and then we wanted to examine risk factors for
increased long coveted neurobehavioral symptoms
and then finally we wanted to apply
a network analysis to investigate the
patterns of somatic cognitive and
emotional neurobehavioral symptoms
in the subsample of Spanish-speaking
individuals with a history of covid-19
positivity and we want to compare that
to a separate non-covet control sample
so we recruited a thousand and
one adults from 32 countries who
had previously tested positive for
covid-19 Via a viral or antigen test
and 650 of these individuals were Spanish speakers
from 26 countries and they averaged 175 days since
their diagnosis or since testing positive for
coven 19. so the data were collected in March to
June 2021 so fairly early in the pandemic and this
is right when vaccinations were beginning to be
rolled out in developed countries and particularly
for high-risk populations so it's important to
say as a caveat the vast majority of people who
participated in this study had not been vaccinated
we also had 443 covid-19 negative
covid-19 negative Spanish speakers
from 19 countries so we knew that
these folks were coveted negative
because we had collected data on
them before the covid-19 pandemic
so participants were recruited
through a professional mailing
lists and collaborators contact networks
so we used Facebook groups we paid for
advertisements on Facebook and then also
we were collaborating with one Center
that had a covid-19 patient database
this was a Mount Sinai in New York
the participants completed an online version of
the neurobehavioral symptom inventory so it's a
22 item self-report measure of symptom severity
across cognitive effective and somatic domains and
it's generally been applied for neurological
conditions like mild traumatic brain injury
so participants reported each symptom
at three time points so before covid
during their covid-19 infection and then
now when they are completing the survey
so here are the results so this is the subscale
score for the somatic symptoms so you can see
over on the left participants free covid-19
scores which as you would hypothesize just shot
up dramatically during the covid-19 infection
and then you also saw some improvement so here
these indices are Cohen's D where point
two is considered a small size effect 0.5
a medium size effect and 0.8 a large size
effect so we see a medium-sized Improvement
in somatic symptoms from during the time of
the covet infection to now but the thing that
was fairly disturbing to me is that there was
a an almost large size effect the Cohen's D of
0.76 from before covid to now in terms of the
increase in somatic symptoms so on average 175
days later we're still seeing an almost large
size increase in reports of somatic symptoms
and then when we broke apart that subscale we
found that the biggest remaining symptoms were
still from uh participants report of their
sense of smell bodily numbness and dizziness
then looking at effective symptoms we saw
that same huge jump and then a small size
Improvement in effective symptoms but a
large size increase in those effective or
emotional symptoms from before covid to
now so we're seeing tremendous continued
mental health problems in individuals who had
a history of covid-19 infection and then within
that subscale the largest continued problems
were pre-coveted fatigue and sleep problems
then for cognitive symptoms again we saw that
huge increase from before kovitz during covid
and then we actually did not find a statistically
significant Improvement in cognitive symptoms
175 days later on average so that Cohen's deed
did not even reach a small size Improvement
conversely there is a large size increase in
cognitive symptoms from before the coveted
pandemic that remained 175 days later on
average within the subscale the largest
continued problems were reports of concentration
problems and then reports of forgetfulness
we then ran some regression models for the
somatic cognitive and effective domains
in step one this was a hierarchical regression
so we had a number of demographic variables
and then in step two we added in a number of
other kind of covid specific variables and so
here I'll just be presenting the results from
step two so we found that people who identified
as male so men reported lower levels of
somatic cognitive and effective symptoms
we found that individuals with another chronic
health condition other than covid reported higher
levels of systematic cognitive and effective
symptoms we found that individuals who had
received oxygen therapy reported lower cognitive
symptoms so again these data are correlational but
you could infer that oxygen therapy um helped
moderate the development of coveted symptoms
individuals who reported higher
covid-19 severity during the time
of infection report a higher somatic
cognitive and effective symptoms
and then unfortunately days since diagnosis
was associated with symptomology but in a
positive direction so greater number of
days since diagnosis we're seeing higher
levels of somatic cognitive and effective
symptomology when we're considering this
cross-sectionally in the context
of the overall regression model
and that is of course controlling
for all of these other variables
uh we decided to look differentially by global
region I will say that interpret these data with
caution because it's hard to know whether a
snowball sampling approach in these different
countries is what uh accounted for some of these
differences you know where you know one person
might have shared it to their Network and then
that network is more homogeneous in a particular
Global region but nonetheless we did find
overall that uh individuals from North America
and Europe and Central Asia reported higher
levels of somatic symptoms severity relative
to those in Latin America and the Caribbean
and relative to those in sub-Saharan Africa
we found that same effect for Effective symptom
severity higher rates in Europe
and Central Asia and North America
and then we found the same effect for cognitive
symptoms severity again highest in North America
followed by Europe and Central Asia and
then sub-Saharan Africa and Latin America
so again you know you're
seeing um kind of traditional
um psychology Behavioral Science approaches
with anovas and regression modeling so we
were interested in applying more modern data
science approaches to our data so we decided
to apply a social network analysis to the 650
Spanish speakers with long coveted and then a
separate sample of 443 individuals without
a covid-19 history so the purpose of social
network analysis is to model among other things
clusters of related symptoms as a dynamic system
so in order to conduct this analysis we
use the estimate Network function from
the bootnet package in R we use the Epic
glasso routine to estimate a network of
partial polychloric correlations which you can
think of as you know partial correlations or a
relationship among variables controlling
for all other relationships in the net
we use regularization which is a machine
learning algorithm that repeatedly reduces
the smallest edges from the network to zero
and then iteratively re-examines model fit
and we compared the two networks so this the uh
650 individuals with the history of long covet or
a history of covid and the 443 individuals without
the cobit history we compared those two networks
statistically using a 500 aeration permutation
test from the network comparison test package in r
all right so graphically here are
the two networks so over on the
left we have the long covid network over
on the right we have the control Network
so yellow nodes or yellow symptoms
are the somatosensory symptoms
the blue symptoms are the cognitive symptoms and
then the green ones are the effective symptoms
so over on the the right is the long covet
Network well we can immediately see is that
by comparison the control network is largely
disjointed relative to the long coveted net
so the somata sensory symptoms kind
of form their own symptom cluster and
don't actually bridge to any of the other
symptoms so it's kind of a diffuse just
pattern of symptoms in individuals without a
history of covid and then in those with long
covid we're seeing actually kind of a organized
interconnected set of neurobehavioral symptoms
then when you look within the models one of
the biggest differences that we found was the
relationship between the organize and headache
nodes so in the long covet group we find a pretty
big connection between those two so the thicker
the line the stronger the connection among those
those variables of those nodes and then we find a
very little connection between the organized and
head headache nodes in the control net so does
that mean that headaches are causing people to
have organizational problems or does it mean that
there might be some organic brain damage in the
context of long covid that's creating headache
pain and then also creating organizational issue
it's hard to know these data are all correlational
but nonetheless we're seeing that those those
two symptoms in particular are highly related to
each other particularly relative to control group
all right so if we're going to draw some
conclusions we have to think about a few
limitations so you know again we used an
online snowball sampling approach and so
there's definitely some non-representativeness
of these samples we're not in any way saying
that this represents um you know
an entire global population clearly
there are a lot of global regions that
were not well represented like in Asia
um also the uh the study was administered
either in English or Spanish and as a result
yeah everybody had to speak those two languages
so there's profound limitations in how far the
um of the data collection can actually
spread just based on linguistic limitations
and you know participants also might have recall
bias when they're comparing their current symptoms
to those either during or before an active
covet infection so um I I would argue that
very likely the uh the reporting of telepsychology
used by psychologists was going to be a lot more
accurate because it's a very kind of concrete
behavioral anchor where when you're thinking
about covid symptoms you have people who have
more mental health issues or more distressed
might retroactively view symptoms that they had
before the pandemic as uh being kind of higher in
magnitude or um you know and so as a result there
is some response bias that you have to take into
account but nonetheless we're very consistently
finding that individuals with that history of
covid are reporting continued symptoms and much
higher symptoms than they had before the pandemic
now in terms of implications um you know it's
just you know we're finding that just incredible
um you know consistency across you
know all three domains of reporting
these substantial continued symptoms um and
so you know we're also seeing evidence that
long covet is a coherent identifiable
pattern of neurobehavioral impairments
now you might find uh this a little bit depressing
uh because you said oh my gosh you know they're
based on you know coveted rates so many people are
probably experiencing these issues and it is true
there are a lot of neurobehavioral impairments out
there that people are experiencing and there are
neuropsychological tests that are showing evidence
of that as well but what I will say is that there
are emerging cognitive Rehabilitation approaches
that have been found to be extremely effective
at treating long-term neurobehavioral symptoms
so I have colleagues at University of Alabama
Birmingham who have found great evidence
already for uh some of their cognitive
Rehabilitation approaches so you can think of
these as like almost you know stereotypically
like brain training games where they do different
types of cognitive exercises um that help people
kind of adjust and you know regain function from
neurological conditions so this has been applied
to traumatic brain injury stroke and now we're
finding evidence that it applies pretty well to
to Long coven and so we're just arguing that those
type of Rehabilitation Services and particularly
cognitive rehab are critical for individuals
reporting elevated long-coveted symptoms
now if I were to take kind of a step back and
obviously this is a data science colloquium series
and so you know here we've showed that a
diverse set of data science approaches for
modeling important features of the covid-19
pandemic can include really a heterogeneous
set of analyzes so things like analyzes of
variance linear regressions path analyzes and
network analyzes and I would argue that each
of these approaches can answer you know very
different research questions even using the same
data set so you know a lot of times researchers
will start off with just describing means and
standard deviations and looking at differences
among groups on some variable of interest and
then maybe they you know work their way up a
little bit further to you know regression models
where they might think of certain predictors and
try to you know fit the best regression model
that they can to you know predicting some outcome
but even still I would argue the field still
needs to you know take those approaches and move
forward so you know have uh theoretical models
that you can test using path analyzes or even
more kind of bottom-up exploratory approaches like
network analysis that don't necessarily presuppose
um a prior existing Theory but nonetheless
can be very complementary because they're
data driven they're inductive rather than
deductive so you know it's really this
combination of traditional and more modern data
science approaches that you can be extremely
synergistic to paint the most comprehensive
and nuanced pictures of patterns and data
all right that's the end of my talk this is my
email address if you have any questions feel free
to get in touch with me and I'm happy to take
any other live questions that you might have
Paul thank you so much um I know that there was a
question that you might have touched on and given
a satisfactory answer but I wanted to kind of
cycle back to it is that in the in your the first
um portion of your talk where you were talking
about like pre-covered there were barriers to the
telepsychology usage by practitioners do you feel
that that was due to just resistance by the the
psychology Community towards the efficacy of it
do you think it was a technological barrier that
people just didn't want to change but kovid's sort
of forced it upon us or do you think that it was a
consequence of the perception that the patients
or the recipients of that that telepsychology
wouldn't get as a a quality experience from
it did you have a sense of that from your data
yeah pre pre-covered we did collect a lot of
data um you know from psychologists on their
perceptions about kind of barriers and and
facilitators of telepsychology use and so
you have a lot of what I call kind of like you
know uh interest psychic barriers so these are
ones that the psychologist perceives um so this
can be things like you know the bias against you
know telepsychology being effective I mean I think
that that's probably a huge one I've heard a lot
of providers especially before the pandemic say
well you know telepsychology is just as not as
effective as when I'm meeting face to face with
with a client or a patient and yet to be honestly
the evidence for that statement is not there um
in fact the vast majority if not all research that
have uncovered has suggested that telepsychology
approaches are just as effective as in-person
approaches now there are some limitations to
that if you think about like a neuropsychological
assessment or other forms of Assessments that
require some sort of like behavioral Criterion
or response from from the patient um it is true
that those are more difficult to administer and
to evaluate you think about like IQ tests for
example are a little bit more difficult to do
um you know over over telepsychology um but yeah
the vast majority of research has suggested that
there's there's no difference the only difference
that has emerged is there's been some research
suggesting that the relationship quality is a
little bit better although a very very small
sized effect better for in person versus over
telepsychology um and then yeah I think a big
issue too is people just were never trained I mean
believe it or not like I mean how many times would
we have zoom meetings before the pandemic existed
like right almost never and so you know people
were using Skype or um you know other approaches
where they would talk to friends and family but
not necessarily in a professional setting all that
often so people just were not familiar with it
and then there also were a lot of I mean I think
in um in defense of psychologists there were there
is there are um patient issues that come up
so you see issues of bandwidth where you know
particularly in rural areas or um you know if
people people are on kind of data limited plans
um it can be very difficult for
them to access telepsychology well
and so yeah I've been randomized clinical trials
looking at the rollout of you know telepsychology
interventions for example for you know caregivers
of older adults and I would say that about a third
of the caregivers we work with are just simply
not able to connect over a smartphone or over
a computer and we have to go through just
straight up you know a telephone so you know
there are those kind of practical barriers but
you know I think a big thing too is just not the
intro psychic but the environmental barriers of um
you know the you know managed payer environments
um you know if if psychologists cannot get
reimbursed for services at the same level that
they can in-person Services despite there being
no evidence that there should be a difference then
um yeah they're going to want to do in-person
work just to Simply you know make more money
and that makes sense right if they're running
a business um and then also there are all these
you know kind of odd ethical issues that
come up across practicing it across state
lines and is it where the psychologist is like
that's where their license is if you go on a
vacation out of out of state then can you no
longer practice or is it where the patient is
um so you know there I think there are some
sort of structural and policy barriers that
create a lot of that resistance as well thank
you Paul um there were in your um your the
study that you described where you're looking at
the various factors that's um contributed to you
know pre-dring and post covid I was struck by
some of the other chronic conditions that you
uh kind of categorized uh but that ended up being
a particularly strong effect and I'm just kind of
wondering if you could comment more on the role
that possibly covet or the experience of covid
may have had on those pre-covered comorbidities
did it like cause them to become worse was it
just kind of compounded and piled on top of them
would they have just experienced you know more
symptomatology more more symptomatology
anyway uh do you have any insights there
Yeah well yeah in some of those regression models
um the presence of uh the additional symptom
was controlling I'm sorry the additional health
condition was controlling for all other variables
in the model including you know severity of
cobit 19. so what we were seeing is that there's
an added burden on neurobehavioral symptoms of
having that additional chronic health condition
um but there has been some research looking at
kind of interactions where you know particularly
people who have cardiovascular issues um how
that impounded with uh with a covid-19 infection
in terms of producing um you know disparate
out outcomes like additional hospitalizations
um you know more neurobehavioral complications
so yeah that's absolutely been a big one
um yes we've we published a study recently looking
at covid-19 vaccination uptake in individuals
with chronic health conditions exactly because
that's that's such an important topic of you
know seeing you know folks who who have those
additional conditions as being you know really
important for you know encouraging higher levels
of vaccination rates to ward off some of these
symptoms that we're seeing here that they're at
additional risk for in your social network kind
of analysis that you performed uh where you
showed that you had certain Bridges between
certainly some of the somatosensory symptomatology
and some of the mental health symptomatology yeah
there thank you for bringing that graph up you
have various what you call Bridges there and I'm
wondering you sort of touched on it about causal
mechanisms here and I'm wondering if you have any
any further comment on those or any other insights
that that people could take away is when they're
performing analyzes like this what they need to
be aware of in terms of making causal inference
yeah causal inferences are super tricky
particularly when you have cross-sectional
data so even though we have this kind
of faux longitudinal data of looking
at these variables and asking people
before during and after the pandemic
the methodology itself of collecting the data
cross-sectionally prevent additional causal
inferences that you might be able to engage
in if you're looking at longitudinal data so
um you know whenever possible if you can conduct
conduct these studies longitudinally do multiple
waves of data collections then you can use
cross-lag panel techniques to help infer
relative causality among pairs of variables and
controlling for other variables within the model
um here yeah I mean this at the end of the day
this is really a cross-sectional model and yes
we're controlling for every other symptom in
the network but you know nonetheless it's it's
cross-sectional so we can't say that one of these
symptoms one of the bridges is due to one node or
One symptom versus another um you can of course
rule out any you know sort of third variables
um by you know controlling for for other
things like if we wanted to control for you
know age or control for presence of another
chronic health condition to say that that's
not causing these relationships but nonetheless
it's very difficult to say that headaches cause
organizational problems or organizational
problems call up cause headaches you know
because the basic structure of the study itself
is not causal so you know in Psychology we have
uh you know an experiment which is uh differed
from other forms of studies like correlational
or cross-sectional studies because the methodology
itself controls for every other possible variable
wherein it's only an experimental manipulation
that can cause a change in a dependent variable
but it is much more difficult to do this uh
cross-sectionally although there are there
are folks who try to do it by just you know
controlling essentially for everything you can
um and then seeing what's left you know and one
of your take-home messages I thought was really
important is the notion of taking a data-driven
approach you can apply some of the methodologies
that you've described here uh you can apply Ai
and machine learning Technologies Etc that are
very popular right now but it's really important
to have a theory of some kind that is testable and
can be validated and can be uh examined that helps
to explain the patterns and the data that you're
seeing so much of our uh I don't know so much of
the stuff what we're seeing these days are oh we
just threw every machine learning algorithm at
the data and we just found the one that classified
you know again the best percentage classifier and
there's no reason other than the math worked out
in our favor and that seems so Theory free that
it is probably worrying especially in cases where
you're looking at clinical kind of predictors do
you have any comments on further comments on that
yeah I mean you know that within the discipline
of psychology there's the famous quote you know
there's nothing so practical as a good theory
and you know I think that psychology tends to be
pretty good at having a theory for how variables
relate to each other what might be causal what
kind of you know Cascade of events might occur
and you know we also have you know decent methods
that have been well accepted in the field like
path analysis structural equation models where
we put we specified a theory ahead of time and
then we collect data to support the hypotheses
that then support that theory um but yeah in the
context of machine learning approaches you know
when I've had conversations with a number of my
colleagues in Psychology about this because this
is a huge area for me he's trying to bring more
machine learning more data science approaches back
to the discipline that I've been trained in um I
do get that resistance you know they say well you
know we're concerned about the replicability of
these models because it you know to some extent
they're based on you know a single sample even
if it's a large stand sample nonetheless it's
sometimes these machine learning algorithms are so
good that they're capturing variants that's there
but it's actually just chance variants relative
to that specific sample right so you know can we
also bring some Theory to the variables that we're
choosing in uh and you know specifying as being
the most important in the context of these models
can we sort of start with that theory and use both
both approaches right I mean there's there's
something about deductive reasoning and you
know deductive science and also about inductive or
more kind of data driven um uh empirically based
science where you know the data are telling you
the story versus you telling the date of the story
and then asking if that's really the story so I
think you have to approach it from from uh really
both methods I think that's a very important point
and thank you Paul for sharing your work with us
and having a little chat with us um we know you're
you have a busy day ahead um so we'll we'll let
you go but thank you so much Paul this was really
great and thank you everyone for joining us and uh
everyone have a wonderful weekend and we'll
see you again next week thank you thank you